el senador por texas muy polémico a
nivel nacional es el que más recibe
dinero por parte de las empresas de
armas en eeuu y el lobby de armas que es
un nuevo los más grandes en este país
estarán también el gobernador de dakota
del sur
kristi noem en la gobernadora de el
gobernador perdón de carolina del norte
también marc globovisión y estará
obviamente donald trump es de resaltar
que en balde llegará el domingo el
presidente joe biden estará acompañando
a las víctimas se hará una nueva iglesia
también en esa ciudad y pues los
funerales las empresas funerarias han
dicho públicamente que no van a cobrarle
a las familias de las víctimas de balde
precisamente después de este tiroteo que
deja 19 niños muertos y 2 profesores
también